>> Will: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT INROADS INTO
UKRAINE.
PETE HEGSETH IS LOOKING AT THE
MAPS.
>> THIS IS A MAP THAT IF YOU
LOOKED A COUPLE DAYS PAST AND
FORWARD, DOESN'T CHANGE THAT
MUCH BUT THAT DOES NOT CHANGE
THE CALCULUS OF THE RUSSIANS WHO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH EVEN MORE
SANCTIONS, HOW THEY WILL DEAL
WITH THAT IS INTERESTING.
THEY ARE CALLING FOR
REINFORCEMENTS FROM AS FAR AS
THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
OUR BORDER ALMOST WITH THEM IN
ALASKA.
YOU'VE GOTTEN REPORTS TONIGHT
THE POTENTIALLY ADDITIONAL
WEAPONS ARE COMING IN.
ANTITANK, ANTIAIRCRAFT WEAPONS
ON BEHALF OF THE UKRAINIANS.
DYNAMICS ARE ALWAYS CHANGING BUT
ULTIMATELY THE RUSSIANS CONTINUE
TO MAKE GAINS.
THEY ARE BOGGED DOWN IN KYIV BUT
THE AIR STRIKES CONTINUE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
LET ME MOVE FORWARD TO THE NEXT
MAP WHICH IS PERTINENT TO SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT, IT'S SO IMPORTANT, IT IS
THE FOG OF WAR.
DO OUR BEST TO BREAK DOWN FACTS
FROM FICTION ABOUT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC FLASH POINTS
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT.
MARIUPOL WOULD CONNECT THE LAND
BRIDGE.
THEY ARE BEING BOMBARDED.
THEY ARE TURNING OFF LIGHTS,
WATER, HEAT, ELECTRICITY, THEY
ARE TURNING OFF THE INTERNET.
IT IS A TOTAL SIEGE.
IN THIS CITY, ULTIMATELY THE
RUSSIANS ARE NOT ATTEMPTED TO
OCCUPY IT.
WHAT THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T DO IS
OCCUPY CITY CENTERS.
THEY HAVE COMMITTED ALMOST 90%
OF THEIR COMBAT FORCE TO UKRAINE
AND THEY CAN'T OCCUPY.
THEY PUT UKRAINIANS SLINKS THERE
BUT THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO STAY.
THEY ARE MOVING ON.
I LOVE WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT AS
FAR AS THE NUCLEAR FACILITY.
YES, SIR, NUCLEAR REACTORS.
THAT WOULD BE CONSEQUENTIAL.
BUT THE BOMBING THAT HAPPENED
WAS ON A ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING
WHICH HAD NO IMPACT.
THE IMPACT IT WILL HAPPEN IS
WHETHER OR NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN
DECIDES TO USE THIS ENERGY AS A
WEAPON AGAINST THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
SO HE'S MOVING FORWARD.
CITY CENTERS, THEY CAN'T CONTROL
THEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE TO KYIV.
>> Will: AS WE TALKED ABOUT,
WE WERE LITTLE TOO QUICK T